part of me is is happy this happened
because why are you happy tell me
the amount of backlash that they did get
because I saw people that you know how I
know when it's not Fanboy stuff when I
when I click on someone talking about it
they ain't following no one I know so
I'm like okay you are definitely not in
this community you are genuine and you
are upset that this game is 30 frames
and I'm like maybe they'll see this out
loud this backlash and they're like okay
someone go over there and tell Bethesda
we need that star field at 60 frames we
can't deal with this anymore they're
like like so you think this sets it off
so but this place could protect
Starfield no it's like this is red fault
okay they are going above and beyond
over redfall what do you think they're
gonna do about Starship
it's like I'm hoping that some way
there's some positivity in this you know
some way that Microsoft sees the the bad
publicity they're like we don't want
that smoke again